the conjuring is based on a true story
it's a family that moves from the city
in Rhode Island of Providence and then
moved into the country and hoping to
start start fresh I play the mother of
these five girls and I'm a really pretty
normal person and happy I get taken over
can be great that's scary
you put in how do you scream they all
kind of brought me to this woman who
teaches you how to scream so I got her
CDs and DVDs so those were some
preparations like vocal warm-ups
physical warm-ups drinking water like it
was almost like a marathon and an opera
I I love scary movies and I think
they're important I think for society
you know they're they're important for
us because I think it's it's just a
really great way for us to deal with
fears and and in a controlled setting I
mean I know just playing games with my
kid you know she loves getting scared as
long as the contract is really clear no
one violates it and I think with a movie
we know what the contract is we're going
in you know we know we're not gonna get
hurt we know it's not gonna really
happen and so it's a great way to get
stuff out
if I saw someone possessed I would I
would go psychiatrist over Vatican route
do you know what I mean because I'd I'd
that's just where I land in terms of
spirits in a house I'm agnostic